quem vocês nunca ouviu a frase
lugar de lixo é no lixo acredito que
todo mundo já tem escutado essa frase
alguma vez na vida
desde pequena a minha mãe sempre me
ensinou a não jogar lixo no chão e
quando jogava
ela fazia eu voltar lá por mais que
tivessem várias pessoas por perto vendo
fazer aquilo
só que eu ficava com vergonha mas enfim
a natureza agradece é e quando não tinha
cesto de lixo por perto ela fala pra
guardar no bolso na bolsa para depois
colocar no lugar adequado então já
cresci com esse pensamento de que o lixo
tem que ter um destino correto
e quando estou andando nas ruas que os
meus amigos e eles jogam lixo no chão eu
peço para eles pegarem imediatamente
inclusive isso aconteceu com a minha
amiga é eu estava andando com minha
amiga mês passado aí ela foi jogou um
papel de bala no chão
aí eu falei a amiga por favor só que aí
ela não quis pagar mas eu peguei só
tentei né
e quando eu vejo alguém jogando lixo no
chão na rua fica assim designada às
vezes até apoio até pega o lixo na
frente da pessoa começar a cair na real
mas na maioria das vezes para ir embora
eu pego e tudo mais
segundo dados da abr
segundo dados de 2015 da abrelpe que é a
associação brasileira de empresas de
limpeza pública e resíduos especiais 76
milhões de toneladas de lixo são
produzidos anualmente no brasil e apenas
3% é reciclada
grande parte desse lixo é destinado a
aterros sanitários onde o lixo é coberto
por terra mas na maioria desses aterros
o solo não é impermeabilizado e os gases
provenientes desses locais não são
espelhos de forma correta e também o
chorume não é tratado
é aí que entra o pnrs
o plano nacional o plano nacional de
resíduos sólidos que visa tentar mudar a
forma de como
tratar o lixo no brasil a proposta do
pnrs é reduzir reciclar e reutilizar o
lixo para que diminua a quantidade de
resíduos encaminhados a lixões a céu
aberto que ainda existem no brasil e
aterros sanitários e também dá um
aproveitamento energético aos gases
provenientes desses locais e tratar o
chorume pra ele ser colocado de volta na
natureza sem agredir inclusive é aqui no
brasil já existem algumas usinas que
utilizam esse tipo de gás pra produzir
energia elétrica mas isso tem que se
tornar bem mais comum
ok quando eu estava no segundo ano do
ensino médio em 2014 começou
chegou o período da feira de ciência da
minha escola e começaram os preparativos
de qual projeto fazer a escolha de
grupos escolha de orientador e teve a
tempestade de idéias que sempre acontece
antes das feiras de ciência e é nela que
o orientador nos incentiva a possíveis
projetos que podem ser feitos e o nosso
orientador nos levou para inspeção nos
arredores da escola na qual tinha muito
lixo de variados materiais e o que mais
se destacava em meio a tanto lixo
variados eram as quantidades de saco de
cimento que tenha lá tenham embalagens
que parecia que estava ali há séculos a
impressão que tivemos é que as pessoas
que faziam construções em casa próximo à
escola
pegavam essas embalagens e simplesmente
simplesmente jogava por cima do muro e
pronto acabou o problema não estou vendo
né
só que não foi aí que começamos a pensar
em um projeto que diminui
significativamente
a poluição na nossa cidade então
pensamos logo nestas embalagens além de
termos visto essa cena ao redor da
escola é nossa cidade existem duas
o crescimento então vamos por aí então
mas assim como o que nós iríamos fazer
com essa embalagem que até então não tem
utilidade alguma por conter restos de
cimento um solvente que é colocado na
embalagem pro sem medo ficar assim ficar
por muito tempo dentro da embalagem
quando retirar fazer a mesma coisa
entendeu é aí nós pensamos por que não
colocar de volta na construção
foi aí que tivemos a idéia de colocar
essas embalagens de volta na construção
por meio de blocos de concreto
então começamos a pesquisar os materiais
que compõem o bloco os convencionais pra
podermos incluir essa embalagem
foi aí que o que eu que criamos é a
nossa primeira metodologia de como fazer
um bloco que era assim eu colocava o
saco de molho é na água normal depois
triturava ele no liquidificador ea água
que o saco ficou de molho ela é
utilizada para tudo assim o tempo pra
ajudar na trituração até porque é no
liquidificador e para a ajudar a
misturar essa essa embalagem triturada
junto com o cimento e areia
após essa mistura após essa mistura é
ele era colocar a essa massa era
colocada numa forma com fundo de tela
para que a água escoasse ea secagem
fosse mais rápida a secagem é feita à
luz solar e vocês podem ter certeza que
a cultura da minha cidade ajudou muito
nessa produção para testarmos a
resistência desse bloco é nós levamos
esses primeiros blocos pra o ifrn que o
instituto federal do estado pra é prata
está na máquina manual de ensaios de
compressão e ele obteve 12 96 mp a mp a
unidade de medida utilizada para ensaios
de resistência à compressão
a aea o projeto conseguiu o segundo
lugar na feira de ciência da nossa
escola é depois vamos apresentar o
projeto é nascer e científica da
secretaria da educação é regional e até
essa feira continuamos pesquisando é
métodos que deixassem o bloco mais
resistente para que ele fosse utilizado
não apenas para o produto para construir
calçadas mais parede também foi aí que
cheguei numa nova metodologia é comecei
mudando as quantidades de areia que
deixar no bloco bem quebradiço
depois é muda é a forma que ele ficou um
pouco diferente eu mudei a forma
coloquei a forma fechada para que a água
fique concentrada e o bloco adquirir uma
resistência ea partir do segundo dia é
que retira do das formas é o comércio eu
começo com a aspersão de água que é
colocar pequenas quantidades de água em
cima do bloco para que ele adquira mais
consistência e não se racha na exposição
contínua ao sol e fica falando eu
misturei eu tô frito rei porque essa
parte de colocar a mão na massa
literalmente é comigo eu pesquiso também
junto com as outras meninas mas essa
parte é única e exclusivamente minha
a aheta estamos é pra comprovar que ele
tem aquele tenha realmente é uma
resistência maior de adquirir na
regência maior
nós fizemos testes na mesma máquina
local do dos blocos anteriores e ele
obteve 5,67 mp após essa feira é
regional
participamos da feira científica
estadual e nela conseguimos várias
premiações incluindo a credencial para
participar da celebração que é a feira
brasileira de ciências e engenharia que
acontece na usp em são paulo e gente
essa foi a primeira feira que eu
participe fora do meu estado e também a
primeira vez que eu viajar de avião bem
emocionante né
também conseguimos a pré-seleção por um
fórum científico em londres e nossa eu
fiquei ultra mega blaster feliz com tudo
o que estava acontecendo e sem acreditar
que um projeto que um projeto tão
simples pudesse conseguir tanta coisa
pudesse projetam sem estudar sozinha a
diferença e conseguir tanta coisa ao
participar da febre a si teve a
oportunidade de apresentar para crianças
jovens adultos pessoas de todas as
idades e o que mais me gratificou foi
poder ver que algo em comum entre todas
elas era o interesse eo entusiasmo em
saber que reciclamos algo até então sem
utilidade alguma a não ser pólo wila e o
processo de avaliação para participar do
fórum científico em londres era
individual os que se saem melhor no
inglês eram selecionados do meu grupo
apenas eu fui selecionada pois uma das
meninas é desistir bem esta prova e
outro teve os problemas e chegou
atrasado no dia da avaliação
eu fiquei bem triste porque seriam menos
chances do projeto é apresentado lá fora
mas vocês também não tem noção da minha
felicidade quando eu soube que eu tenho
sido selecionada a primeira coisa que
vem à minha cabeça foi o projeto
ecológico do interior do rio grande do
norte é selecionado para participar de
fórum científico em londres e eu
consegui apresentar o projeto lá fora
dando o meu melhor para representar
todos que ajudaram o projeto e as
meninas do grupo e o nosso orientador e
eu super meio ter participado e foi
incrível e sabem uma das milhares de
coisas que eu percebi em londres foi que
nas ruas também tem lixo no chão claro
não tanto quanto aqui no brasil mas tem
sim
aí eu pensei
pintamos políticas públicas que
incentivam as pessoas a não fazer isso e
mesmo assim não é suficiente
aí eu percebi que a preservação do meio
ambiente não está achando que os
governantes podem fazer para melhorar
isso mas sim o que nós cidadãos comuns
podem fazer então tudo começou da
consciência da minha mãe em ensinar que
lugar de lixo não é natureza espalhado
por aí e com esse ensinamento eu tive e
ensinamento me levou até o interesse de
contribuir com o meio ambiente através
desse projeto científico hoje e
abrangência internacional
apesar de todas as dificuldades que
enfrentamos sendo aluno de escola
pública com professores que nos
incentivam e acredito no nosso potencial
poderemos chegar onde quisermos e
promover mudanças não só em nossas
cidades mas no mundo porque a partir do
momento em que mudamos o pensamento de
alguém que joga um simples papel zinho
de bala no chão que até então acha que
por ser pequeno não vai poluir
isso já é uma mudança mundial porque
essa pessoa vai mudar esse pequeno e
esse pequeno erro não é que a jogar um
pequeno papel de bala no chão e vai
mudar e se pensa e se vai mudar o
pensamento do outro coleguinha dela e do
outro coleguinha aí o que acontece
todo mundo fica legal e não que as
grandes organizações que incentivam as
pessoas a não jogar papéis de bala no
show grandes lixos não faça uma
diferença também
mas eu não quero dizer que as pequenas
ações também tem muita importância e
além dessas feiras e fóruns científicos
que eu já citei eu participei da
mostratec que é uma feira que no super
maravilhosa também e eu eu ganhei um
prêmio é nunca de um canal de tv a cabo
internacional é no qual o nome da
categoria que estava participativa
concorrendo era melhoradores vamos 1
melhorar o mundo olha esse homem que é
incrível mesmo que eu não tivesse
ganhado eu já estava me sentindo tempo e
ardeu gol
o ior do tio
enfim o que eu acredito é que a
diferença não está achando que se inicia
grande mas também está presente nas
pequenas ações no fazer a sua parte e
hoje eu não consigo mais usar algo sem
pensar meu deus o que eu vou fazer com
essa embalagem eu não posso simplesmente
jogar no lixo
muito obrigado